es miércoles y en la casa de luz en sant
dennis es día de hacer arepas para la
colombiana de 78 años a quien conocimos
hace un año en la cola de la ayuda
alimentaria el fin de las restricciones
no la ha sacado de su precariedad como
aunque ha retomado las horas de limpieza
que realizaba en la distintas casas en
parís sigue dependiendo de las ventas de
los que llama panqueques colombianos
para mejorar sus ingresos cada fin de
mes su mayor preocupación es el pago del
alquiler estoy mejor se y mejor más
tranquilita porque siquiera estoy al día
con el evento
le debo a mi hermana una plática pero yo
espero ahora que pasen estas vacaciones
pues le abonaría una porque ahora se van
las patronas quedamos
sin trabajito
y espero que la gente con maletas a ver
tras el reportaje en france 24 toda una
cadena de solidaridad virtual se creó en
torno a luz varias personas en su
mayoría colombianas en parís y en el
extranjero le aportaron con dinero que
le permitió pagar su deuda de alquiler
son ayudas excepcionales lo sabe que sin
papeles no tiene derecho ningún aporte
económico del estado con la ayuda de la
humanitaria que la gente me dio cancele
lo que debía y ya pues estoy al día
gracias adiós
lo más importante en mi ayuda medical
que lo queme con eso no tengo que pagar
nada de medicamentos ni en nada
en francia la vida parece retomar su
curso pero en el caso de luz ella sigue
dependiendo de la alimentaria
la pedía antes de la pandemia y la sigue
solicitando hoy y es que el cobismo hizo
sino agravar su situación de precariedad